I've come to the end of my week in
Vietnam and it's been a culinary trip
into the unknown and the unthinkable
my mentor V said one week would not be
enough to master this ku scene and I'm
about to find out if she was right
I'm in Hanoi to cook a dinner for V and
other top tutors I've met this week mr.
rice
hi sir oh yeah good how you doing yeah
well thank you this place looks amazing
please hello beautiful mrs. ducks friend
mr. rice has given me the use of his
fine dining restaurant a success is
built on authentic Vietnamese cooking
and so it's a great honor
the rest is beautiful thank you who
designed it I designed myself good job
worryingly for me mr. rice has invited
along 30 discerning diners you got a
huge huge challenge and you know tonight
so many people here just waiting for
your cooking and I say about 6-7 people
very tough really in three hours the
restaurant will be full and I need to
quickly get used to these unfamiliar
surroundings Wow this is the kitchen
yes everything here tonight yours yeah
gas burners and Grill completely
different layout of a kitchen it's not
like working with a gas spring burner
ten times more powerful a lot more
instant so on the fly yet again tonight
my menu will be drawn on everything I've
learned I'm cooking pig seven ways fresh
spring roll yeah we served at room
temperature be very careful a pig's ear
salad blanched and a nice sort of spicy
broth barbecued pork skewer and it's
build over charcoal I'm never gonna go
to the sweet sour pork ribs
okay after them you've got a pig's
Trotter curry after that Karen eyes pork
belly finish with fish sauce half that
the pork noodle broth let's go bye-bye
my nose-to-tail menu is a tall order
I start with barbecued pork skewers
inspired by Missy's duck
the shoulder of pork sliced thinly it's
marinated and then cooked on charcoal
now that doesn't look anywhere near like
mrs. ducks
times like this so we should just give
me the recipe properly I think it's
secretly because she had a massive crush
on me and she had visions of her and I
setting up a restaurant together next
for my pig feast I carried that I hope
will satisfy the Vietnamese appetite for
texture home in the UK we bone them out
and stuff them but these are cooked on
the bone and very gelatinous nice fact
oberek little bit of garlic ginger fish
sauce a little bit of fermented rice
wine vinegar almost like a sort of like
spicy curry the pressure is on and
already I've made my first mistake so
this is my broth remember my singing
Odile down the river I'm just struggling
for that nice sort of lightly sort of
pinkish colour I'm beginning to wish I'd
kept things simple